Garet, idiot, est-ce qu'ils se sont tous
échappés, c'était proche
Oh aucun oui nous avons du bon travail pour vous les
gars oh oui petit chien nous avons votre ami
m'avantage oh ignorez simplement ce qui vient de se
passer d'
accord qui êtes-vous les gars hein qui sommes-nous qui
sommes-nous, nous sommes les animaux de compagnie
jetés par nos propriétaires et maintenant nous voulons nous
venger, c'est comme un club, mais avec des morsures
et des grattages, emmenez-nous avec vous,
je ne pense pas que les
animaux de compagnie s'en soucient, vous devez coudre la
domestication partout  toi tu as choisi
ton camp et maintenant tu vas brûler sans
arrêt
qui tu appelles des animaux de compagnie je ne suis pas un animal de compagnie tu as
tout faux mots mots juste comme
vous les gars nous détestons les humains
sur les
gens d'accord mec ouais c'est pourquoi nous avons
brûlé nos colliers mec il les a brûlés
jusqu'au sol il a tué nos propriétaires mais attendez
une minute c'est trop loin peut-être non ils le
creusent oui nous l'avons frappé ouais c'est
vrai bang-bang avec nos propres pattes je
J'ai un centime pour chaque propriétaire que j'ai tué oh ouais
j'ai un centime parce que je viens  J'ai tué celui que
Katie a ramené à la maison un nouveau chien de la
fourrière elle a dit que c'était mon frère je ne veux pas de
frère et je n'ai même pas de
lit maintenant je dors par terre
comme un chien
pourquoi  Est-ce que Katie me ferait ça parce
qu'elle est une personne de chien Max et les gens de chien font
des choses étranges et inexplicables comme ils ont des
chiens au lieu de chats d'accord s'il vous plaît ne
commencez pas maintenant Chloé qui n'aide pas max
allez je suis ton ami d'accord et comme ton
ami, je dois être honnête avec toi,
je me fiche de toi ou de tes problèmes,
mais si tu ne fais rien à propos de ce
gars et bientôt ta petite vie parfaite
avec ton idiot, l'humain sera
fini pour toujours pour toujours ouais c'est
quoi  Je viens pourquoi cette souris est-elle sur mon passé
Elle Oh Duke Gill Katie n'est pas Katie
va être si bouleversée quand elle verra que
Katie va s'énerver quand elle verra comment
tu as saccagé toute sa place oh c'est juste que
c'est juste un visage est-ce Duke est-ce  ah
c'est dommage qu'est-ce que tu fais
whoa qu'est-ce que je fais oh rien je suis je suis
une coupure  e petit toutou je Katie sait que je
ne ferais rien comme ça
non non whoa hmm
cela ne pourrait être que le travail d'un
dangereux errant qui n'a pas établi une
base de confiance tu es le nouveau chien
et Wayne goop pourquoi  tu vas faire ça
pour oh je vais ce qui me mord arrache mon visage
parfait attends jusqu'à ce que Katie découvre
oh bien Katie Dieu merci tu es là
j'ai essayé de l'arrêter mais il est fou
hmm maintenant assis